-As the Senate impeachment trial
enters its next phase,
the President and his lawyers
have gone from arguing
that there was no quid pro quo
to arguing that
the President can do literally
whatever he wants.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Democratic House prosecutors
have laid out a very clear,
specific, detailed case against
President Trump.
He held up hundreds of millions
of dollars in aid to Ukraine
in order to extort that country
to help him cheat
in the 2020 election by digging
up dirt on Joe Biden.
Congressman Jason Crow,
a combat veteran,
put it in very simple terms.
-We are here for one reason
and one reason only.
The President
of the United States
withheld foreign aid
that he was happy to give
in the two prior years,
that suddenly we are
to believe something changed,
the conditions
on the ground changed
and he had an epiphany
about corruption
within a week
of Vice President Biden
announcing his candidacy.
It doesn't make any sense.
-No, it doesn't, mostly
because Trump isn't capable
of having an epiphany.
His brain is only capable of
firing one neuron at a time.
If he ever tried to do
a math problem,
he'd forget to breathe
and pass out.
That's why he looks dead into
the camera with that blank stare
like a deer caught
in a nature video.
Not only has Trump never heard
of an epiphany in his life,
if you asked him what
an epiphany was,
he'd probably say,
"The daughter who hates me?"
[ Laughter ]
"She's a real piphany."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And as the Democratic House
prosecutors have laid out
their evidence in the Senate
impeachment trial,
President Trump's defense team
has struggled to respond.
It's getting harder and harder
for Trump to insist that
the investigation is a so-called
witch hunt.
And I mean it's literally
getting physically harder
for him to say
the words "witch hunt."
-The American people are
disgusted by
the Washington Democrat wish --
And you see it.
You see it.
Seth: "Wish -- what -- what --
Witch, witch, what?"
[ Laughter ]
We don't. We don't know
what you said.
Why does he always do that thing
where he just quickly moves on
and pretends he didn't mess up
instead of just stopping
and correcting himself?
It's not a slick move, dude.
It makes you sound like a stoner
with a mouth full
of peanut butter.
[ Mumbling ]
Witch, witch, was.
And when he's not complaining
about a witch hunt,
Trump has repeatedly claimed
that Article 2
of the Constitution,
which outlines
the powers of the presidency,
allows him to do literally
whatever he wants.
-Article 2 allows me to do
whatever I want.
Then I have an Article 2,
where I have the right to do
whatever I want as President,
but I don't even
talk about that.
Nobody ever mentions
Article 2.
It gives me all of these rights
at a level that nobody
has ever seen before.
-What do you mean nobody
has ever seen before?
Only Trump would think,
"No one ever gets to that part
because it's all the way back
in Article 2."
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
I doubt Trump has ever read
even one full sentence
of the Constitution.
He probably got three words in
and quit.
"We, the people? I think that
'M' is upside down."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Or maybe, maybe it's possible --
it's possible Trump just got
some bad legal advice.
After all, look who's
representing him
in the impeachment trial.
Here's one of his lawyers,
Pam Bondi,
the former Attorney General
of Florida trying to claim
that Joe Biden's son,
Hunter, was corrupt
and worth investigating,
except she clearly
could not find her notes
and was lost without them.
-He remained on the board...
[ Laughter ]
...until...
...April...
[ Laughter ]
...of...
...2019.
[ Laughter ]
-Pam Bondi...
...you...
[ Laughter ]
[ Bleep ]
...up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Where --
[ Cheering continues ]
Where does Trump
find these lawyers?
Did he see her on a bus stop
bench ad?
Or just on a bus stop bench?
She's like a failed game show
contestant whose fallback career
was defending the President.
Ms. Bondi, who is
Hunter Biden?
-He remained on the board...
[ Laughter ]
...until...
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
I have not seen
a swing and a miss that bad
since that British lady whiffed
on Greta Thunberg's name.
-The 2019 book entitled
"No One Is Too Small
to Make a Difference"
is a collection of speeches
made by
a Swedish climate change
activist.
What's her name?
-Sharon.
-Greta Thunberg.
[ Laughter ]
-She looks like a Sharon.
But Trump's claim that he can do
whatever he wants
is very much at the core
of Trumpism
and the modern Republican Party.
And that ethos is very much
on display
in this impeachment trial.
Republicans have spent
a decade pretending to be
a principled party based on
limited government
and respect for
the Constitution,
where in reality they never
cared about any of that stuff.
Today's Republican Party is
an authoritarian movement
led by people who believe
they should have the power
to impose their will
on everyone else.
And Trump perfectly embodies
that authoritarian mindset,
which was on display
in its clearest
and most obvious form yesterday
when Trump lawyer
Alan Dershowitz
made a truly shocking
argument that it doesn't matter
if Trump engaged in
an illegal quid pro quo
to cheat in the 2020 election,
because if he was doing
something to help himself
get re-elected, that means
he was also doing it
in the national interest.
-Every public official
that I know
believes that his election
is in the public interest.
And mostly you're right.
Your election is
in the public interest.
And if a president
does something
which he believes will
help him get elected
in the public interest,
that cannot be
the kind of quid pro quo
that results in impeachment.
-That is an absolutely
insane argument
that is antithetical
to literally everything
the Founders believed when
they wrote the Constitution.
Think about what he's
saying there.
He's saying that if you believe
you being president
is what's best for the country,
then you're allowed to do
whatever you want
in order to remain president.
That's insane.
By that logic,
Trump could shut down airports
under the pretense
of high winds any time one of
his Democratic challengers
had a flight, which would affect
everyone but Bernie
who likely has a backup mule.
[ Laughter ]
"Mules are stubborn,
no-nonsense and affordable,
just like me."
[ Laughter ]
"I will see you in Iowa
in one week."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, to give you an idea of how
utterly bankrupt and amoral
this idea is, let's just
step back and review
how much the Trump team's
argument has changed
over the last few months.
Because as you just heard,
one of the President's lawyers
literally just said that he can
commit an illegal quid pro quo
to cheat in an election
and that's fine.
But, as you'll recall, when
the allegations first emerged,
Trump and his supporters
insisted adamantly
over and over and over again
that no such quid pro quo
had ever occurred.
-There's no quid pro quo,
no demand,
no pressure, no threat.
-There's no quid pro quo.
-There was no quid pro quo.
-There is no quid pro quo.
-There is no
quid pro quo.
-There was no quid pro quo.
-There was no
quid pro quo.
There was no quid pro quo.
But listen to this.
There is no pro quo.
-That's right it.
[ Laughter ]
There was no pro quo.
I guess we can't expect the
President of the United States
to remember that many
one-syllable words.
When Eric and Don Jr. were
growing up, he probably
read them a book called
"The Cat in The."
[ Laughter ]
"No pro quo" sounds like
a fake phrase a New Yorker
would say to a tourist
in Times Square
to avoid talking to them.
[ Laughter ]
"Excuse me, can you tell us
where the M&M Store is?"
"Scusi, no pro quo."
[ Laughter ]
So that was their argument
at the start.
Fast-forward to Tuesday amid
the Senate impeachment trial
when Senator Ted Cruz
took a rehearsal break
from his
one-man Unabomber musical
to argue that
it doesn't matter
if there was a quid pro quo.
-The Constitution requires
high crimes or misdemeanors.
That the test for impeachment,
it's treason, bribery, or other
high crimes and misdemeanors.
And the House Democrats,
they haven't alleged
any crime whatsoever.
One point that explains why
the President is innocent
and he should be acquitted
and why he will be acquitted.
Quid pro quo doesn't matter.
It's a red herring.
It doesn't matter if there was
a quid pro quo or not.
-Oh, now it doesn't matter?
You guys have spent
the last four months insisting
it didn't happen.
When you suddenly change
your argument like that,
it makes it obvious
it did happen.
If you worked at Dunkin' Donuts
and your boss said to you,
"Hey, Brad, did you stick your
[bleep] through the crullers?"
and you said,
"Of course not,"
and then he asked you again,
and you said,
"It doesn't matter, crullers
taste like [bleep] anyway!"
[ Laughter ]
Then, yeah,
you stuck your [bleep]
through all the crullers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In fact, Ted Cruz himself,
he once argued there was
definitely no quid pro quo.
-A lot of what the Democrats
had been raising,
alleging an illegal
quid pro quo was not,
in fact, backed up
by the transcript.
-First of all, it wasn't
a transcript.
The transcript is still in some
secret server
with a ton of what I'm sure
is other incriminating material.
And second of all,
even the readout
the White House released backed
up the quid pro quo.
When you offer someone something
of value, and then literally
in the next breath say,
"I would like you to do us
a favor though," as Trump did
on his phone call
with the President of Ukraine,
that is the literal definition
of a quid pro quo.
And if that person
turns it down,
the only polite thing to
say is...
-No pro quo.
[ Laughter ]
-These guys can't keep
their talking points straight
because they don't have
a coherent defense.
Just watch this awkward moment
from Sean Hannity's
Fox News show where he tried
to tick through four supposed
facts that explain
why Trump is definitely
innocent,
and then tossed to GOP
Congressman Jim Jordan
to explain the fourth fact,
but Jordan seemed
to have no idea
what he was supposed to say.
-Jim Jordan, four facts
never change,
and why is that relevant
again tonight?
Because let's say John Bolton
said the President vented.
President said, "Ah, I --
they better do this
or they're not
getting any money."
The fourth fact is?
[ Laughter ]
Of your facts, the fourth fact
is it doesn't matter, does it?
'Cause he didn't do it.
-Ha, ha.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
That was the equivalent
of watching someone
pass a basketball to a teammate
who's not looking
and have it bounce
right off their face.
Even Pam Bondi was like,
"Get it together, guys."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's lawyers and allies
can't keep their talking points
straight because it's all B.S.
They're making up stuff
off the top of their heads
to mask the only real argument
they actually have,
which is this -- they want to
keep Trump in office,
and in order to do that,
they have to agree
he's above the law.
They've said as much
throughout
this impeachment trial.
The Republican Party is an
authoritarian movement
beholden to their
cult-like leader.
That's been clear
since the moment
Trump announced his candidacy.
But it's been especially obvious
since at least...
-April...
[ Laughter ]
...of...
[ Applause ]
...2019.
-Oh, Pam!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This has been "A Closer Look."